all right Billy so Mark welcome back
look at you all dressed up this time
it's time to make sure I look a little
bit better than the last time I didn't
really like that uh that look you mean
yeah well you you were you're had a
meeting with your lawyer today yeah I
had me with my lawyer and let me tell
you anybody out there that's doing
anything with lawyers that's the worst
thing you could ever do man lawyers are
garbage and all these personal injury
attorneys that's all they're doing is
trying to take your money and that's the
way it is so
uh yeah it's down on lawyers but you're
uh but you're fighting a case I think
the one you described last time yeah
find the gun case and uh luckily I
myself I want proper on that too I mean
and uh I'll probably be beating that you
know I mean hopefully uh the cop uh
didn't wear his body cam didn't follow
his own procedures
um so all I got to do is prove that in
court you mean but uh it's cool because
like when you're in custody they don't
tell you that
that the whole thing is it's like a
theatrical um
it's a it's a mirage you know what I
mean the DA's act like they're all mean
that's the role they play the judge
plays some some uh supposedly referee
your attorneys are against you I mean
it's like my brother got broke off 32
years and it's like
if you want to just listen to me like if
there's anybody that's fighting a case I
want anybody out there to know this
fighting the case these lawyers
everything's against you the county jail
is used as some mental like breakdown to
break you down mentally I mean just like
torture and then your your lawyers are
all against you they're they're for the
they're for the courts you know then
you're giving them your your your voice
is getting given to them immediately and
that's why you get looked at like you're
stupid but if you go to the court just
looking like this you don't even have to
know law really I mean they have to help
you along the way but you go in there
looking good talking good being polite
and just learn yourself along the way
YouTube have to be I mean if you have to
but don't give it don't give in the
power that's where it's all that's where
everybody's getting broke off and
everything's a plea bargain with them
you know
and then there's an underground level of
it too that's going on like because
really when you're in court there is no
such thing as criminal code you're
violating uh Federal codes we're not
federal employees you know what I'm
saying we're citizens but we don't know
that so we go up in there thinking hey
that's what's happening here and it's
really Commerce law where you're being
sued you know I mean but they take you
as piece of property because you don't
know no better your name is being sued
by a business entity to be milk the
trust that you have and there's like a
lot going on like the judges the lawyers
all of them get they're all financially
interested and you go to jail I mean and
you and you give them time and you give
them like a pound of Flesh and money I
mean and nobody knows that but it
doesn't take you really like a brain
surgeon or anybody like that I mean I've
been going to jail since I was 11. so I
will say I've been in a lot of
courtrooms and I just eventually started
looking at it like there's something up
here dude like when you see a lawyer
come in he looks like crap and you're
like really like this dude can pack this
law I couldn't practice law oh I don't
know you mean you know I go in there
looking like that and they're like
stating I'm counseling me I go up in
there and it's about looking apart you
mean Chloe's make the man yeah heck yeah
close making man it's a uniform you
decide to wear that's why I chose to
wear this today besides the business I
had to conduct I was just I didn't
really like the last time I was on here
I looked a little little grudged out you
know I mean I wish we could dress like
this like this is back in the day your
man I was dressed like this all the time
that's right
so do you regret getting in this whole
life that you've been living where
you're you're in and out of well
remember last time I said I didn't have
a regrets right but that was actually
obviously accurate because nobody wants
to go to prison nobody wants to do the
stuff that I've done and now here I am
almost 40 years old and I can honestly
say that I do have some regrets I mean
but not the regressive like my character
you mean what defined me what's made me
who I am now wouldn't have been achieved
had I not been able to go through the
struggles and tribe trials and
tribulations but I will say that going
to prison wasn't ideal I mean I mean
those are years I can never get back and
I just have to I have to look at a
positive side because what other choices
do I have I would have got out and be
like oh you know down on the outs I have
to look at it it's like that time was
whatever was meant for you I mean why do
you think your life took that path uh
honestly
your dad was not really involved in it
well my dad my dad's my dad said it said
hi he set the standard like because
that's what people look for you know and
they look for the man especially a boy
he's looking for an adult figure a male
figure that's gonna guide him I mean my
dad he he followed his dad's uh
you know influence and I follow my dad's
influence so I really my dad did play a
base the biggest role on me because I
was towards that but like some of the
stuff that grounded me with my
grandmother my mom but Society itself
like the communities that we got the
lower the lower income communities
is going to produce that I mean if you
don't have money if you don't have
nothing and we're all living insane
that's why like the race I can
understand there's race in America we
all know that right but
you ain't I don't think that's a decided
Factor because look if I walk down the
streets dressed how I was the other day
when I was the last time I interviewed
right I walked out she's tatted up with
the tank top on so I believe I'm getting
sweated just as much as anybody else
they don't have to be black to get
sweated like that and I sure I've been
going to court since I was a kid and
judges were white lawyers were white all
of them were white they didn't give me
no deal I was getting broke off just the
same amount of time they were like oh
you're white buddy you don't trigger you
know you mean I'm still getting broke
off like do you own this suit or you
rent it no I bought the suit you bought
this yeah it's gonna be good good
investment too yeah
save you some time yeah it saved me a
lot of time and a lot of uh like I said
it's all about perception you know what
I mean
you got like I was I was watching
something the other day and they were
talking about three levels three lives
or whatever you got you know you got you
got your private life you got your
personal life and you got your public
life you mean we all three where we all
y'all you like kind of hide your public
life from certain things I mean and so
how you look is how you is how you get
perceived and that's really literally
how how simple it is I mean you want you
don't want to get sweated you don't
dress like that you know what I mean you
got game beers I'm black I'm just pulled
over dude if you if you wear that outfit
that's what you're gonna get if you're
walking down street your tattoo you're
gonna get you're gonna you're gonna get
profiled you mean and I don't even trip
on I trip on that too it's probably why
how can you hold them to a standard not
profiling somebody when you're literally
give them a job to try to eliminate
crime before it even happens right
that's a hard job you know when you
think about it I'm not saying I'm Pro
like all the way Pro crop but I'm saying
that it's stupid some of the stuff that
we we're dealing with in society now
really pisses me off dude I mean like
I don't even know where this world's
going these days
it's kind of crazy so much of the
impression that people will make on
others is the way they speak
yeah for sure I see that in the hood a
lot where people are just speaking a
certain way and they're never going to
get a break no no not talking like that
well vocabulary that's the most that's
the most like freshest thing that you
can have like like your world your world
actually is divine by your vocabulary
really like you think if you could only
Define if you could only describe
something with one word cool cool cool
you're limited I mean even your your
horizons are limited if you can put it
some kind of spice in your vocabulary
that's that carries a long way down
people respect people that can talk
articularly or articulate their opinions
or whatever you mean and sometimes
people just need to shut the hell up you
know I mean like they talk too much I
mean but if you talk with some kind of
uh confidence and some kind of authority
you're gonna feel like you're having a
better time getting through this you
know and men in general need to men
nowadays need to start looking at
towards that you mean how you present
yourself how your reputation is who you
are who you want to be those are things
that you should be concentrated on but
everybody out here is concentrating on
the worst [__] ever it seems like I mean
what do you think is going on in our
society where you see so many young men
who are just like focused on
honestly I know what's going on the
government wants to the government right
now is straight up breaking down any
kind of form of masculinity that they
can find because who takes on tyranny
masculine men you break the masculine
Min down you got no problems on your
hands these government controls we're
already getting to the point where now
if we don't come and push some kind of
line back it's going to be a serious
situation dude like what nobody on this
planet is going to see what's really
coming I mean not there's not a lot of
guys cut from your cloth anymore nah
they said no yeah I was watching some of
the other thing dude some Navy SEAL was
talking about how there's like 100
people in a class as of right now right
and they only they only really are able
to get six out of 100 class right they
say by the next couple Generations they
won't even be able to do that wouldn't
be able to fill a class up they're gonna
have to drop the standard or deal with
what we got that's pretty scary dude I
mean
I'm pretty scared dude but like I said
you gotta Something's Gotta Give dude
because this is getting really out of
hand like you know really out of hand
he's disgusting Something In The Water
the cell phones or this yeah and I don't
understand what this whole like the
worst thing to be on the planet is a
single white male or whatever you mean
like we gotta we got a bad dog white
privilege and all these white guilt and
[__] that's crazy to me dude I mean I
don't even understand it like people
know the history out there now by now
with that internet you know the history
right like we all got top bunk ass
[__] whatever history but now you
have to access the internet so you have
access to [__] and we're all still blind
to that [__] man stupid like do you want
to blame the stupidest things and waste
your time I think this whole transgender
thing is just a it's just something to
keep us all preoccupied too to from
what's really happening you're like what
the [__] is going on I mean that shit's
stupid as hell
it's a crazy world right now yeah do you
castrating children yeah that's weird
dude like that's a straight attack on on
everything man you can't change you
can't change things like that you know
but I think it's just an illusion to
keep us
I don't know just keep us all pinned
down and fighting with each other
because that's how they do divide and
conquer I mean if everyone's fighting
about something dude then you forget who
the hell you mean and they're bar on
both sides that's how they always man do
you have kids yeah I have kids I got two
sons I got my son Nicholas
well I'm having a hard time with he just
got busted recently
I got busted he's doing uh
about busting for stone car or something
is that something you learned from his
dad if you learn it from me you wouldn't
be getting busted for it
well I mean yeah I don't yeah he's busy
kind of easy for it but
um yeah my son yeah he busted and I had
to take care of my grandson he made me a
grandpa at 39 years old
but uh I'm worried about him you know
but boys boys challenge their fellow
there's more than they challenge anybody
else so
and then with my baby's mom like
I don't know what's up with her dude
like I just me and her I thought she was
gonna be the one I was gonna be with the
rest of my life you know I loved her
eight years I thought she was in my like
she was my perfect balance and it turned
out it ain't and it's just when you come
to that realization it's hard to um
Charlie said you know and then when you
have a child in the way and two people
split and said the way they split and
then one gets the other it gets that the
responsibility and everything and has
the control over it it really puts the
other person on it and then bad spot
dude I'm really like struggling with it
because
Jason he's so young I just want to have
I want to be able to get that influence
that I couldn't have had with Nick and
that's what impacted my relationship the
most is not being there for like the way
I needed to be trained our relationship
we're now here as an adult
the relationship is just too strange to
uh for him to look towards me and for
guidance or whatever he needs to look
for and that's troubling you mean and I
know Jason I was starting to build a
really deep bond with him and for her to
be off doing her thing and I wanted to
clarify last time because I kind of I
spoke derogatory derogatorily about her
in a sense that I understand that she's
doing what she's doing because she got
sober and she really does want to do
what's best for chasing you know and a
lot of things I've said in In the Heat
of the Moment or whatever wasn't the
right stuff to say about somebody you
know a lot of people that you love about
if you love them you should just
withhold some of the bad feelings you
have towards stuff that's happening I
mean and I do love her but I want to I
want to be a part of my son's life no
matter what and she's not
willing to give me that maybe maybe I'm
[__] it up I don't know maybe I just
couldn't pull it out or whatever but do
you think there are things about your
demeanor about your personality that
just yeah [__] yeah definitely I'm like
you know you repel people you've I can
sit here and be like no it ain't my
[__] [__] but it is my [__] like I am
hard to deal with I understand that I
mean but there's pros and cons to that
you know what I mean I mean I can't help
my all my life I've been in prison I
mean like I wish it wasn't that way but
when you take a kid and put them in
there and that's the environment I grew
up in so they take me outside of that I
think I'm doing pretty good for somebody
that had that much time under his belt
got out here I pretty much done besides
the [__] I've got into since I've
been out here which I guess is pretty
big but I still not here you know I mean
I'm still trying I'm still trying to
function out here I'm not I could have
pulled the trigger a long time ago
because that's what a lot of people do
in the situations that we come from the
car as cons it's really easy for us to
just fall back into that a lot of us
don't even know we we're doing it I mean
but I got to a place where I was so
uncomfortable in there like literally
uncomfortable that I can't find I'm like
going back there's an impossibility for
me I mean like it's like so something
about my brother in them they just some
people just rather pull the core dude
because it's just too much to be all
this pressure it's easier for them to be
in prison it is than outside and it's
kind of a cop-out but it's it's sad but
I mean what do you expect when you put
somebody in a structured place where
they're at least their basic needs are
met fundamentally it means so what are
you gonna do when you put them out here
tell them here you got to figure it out
you gotta you gotta expect them not to
want to do that I mean it's not a really
bad thing to him but I think if they
took more time spending more money on
really trying to direct
some kind of Rehabilitation I mean it's
hard to say that because I I know when I
was in prison like there's a lot of
people that were offered a lot of groups
they could see her and say whatever they
want like oh you know nothing there man
I can't get a job that's [__] I mean
but people don't have the incentive to
do that when they're already beat down
to a pulp you mean it's like you you
know I wake up in the morning feeling
good about yourself when you feel like
[__] every day you know so I can
understand that but at the same time you
only live once dude you don't think
prison
rehabilitates at all it gives you it
gives the illusion that the options are
there it is up for you but I mean
as far as Rehabilitation you can't you
can't expect to really walk away as a
reformed person by any means there's no
possible way it's more likely you'll get
institutionalized that's first that
comes first you or your State's
institutionalize if you're able to pick
out little little aspects or little
little uh you know little Trinkets and
put it up to your character and go like
ah like me I got a GED I got a couple a
degrees but I was stabbing people at the
same time I'm like playing butchering
people on the yard and [__] and I'm like
yeah you mean so it really it's really
whatever it's up to you I mean yeah
whatever accomplishments you get if you
use them for the benefit of something
positive you're gonna get positive
outcome you mean if you don't
this life you get homie that hardcore
life
and if you can live it you live it stop
bitching about it you mean but I just
look nowadays I just look at it like
this you want to be a good person you'd
be a good person everybody out here has
a judge me to somebody everybody wants
to talk about this or that or uh this
[__] [__] why are you wasting your
time you only live once dude you only
live one time to be here so why don't
you shut the [__] up and just
hear me because you're gonna waste all
your time talking about somebody else
and then guess what your shit's up
time's up you mean so I'm not gonna do
that anymore I'm trying just to below
the navigational beacons and
are your sons similar to you in terms of
personality
well they look just like me so you know
fall I guess it didn't fall far from the
important blog I hope they're better
than men than I am I mean a lot of
aspects I mean I hope I hope they're
able to if they have kids they love them
and try to realize that it's probably
more beneficial to dedicate yourself to
loving them and being there for them you
know
it's more rewarding I mean how well do
you know you're 30 39 39 if you had your
life to live all over again would you
have done things differently hell yeah I
do hell yeah I would have what I would
have done from the start was I would
have started concentrating like you know
when you ask a kid what do you want to
be when you grow up I would have
literally at that age I don't know how I
would have had that instilled with me
but I would have figured out what I
wanted to be and I would have dedicated
it because that's what they say
manifestation comes from dedication of
something that you want from the
beginning of time until you just don't
stop until you get it right so
I don't know whatever it would have been
I would have liked to be a military
yummy I would like to be like kind of
some Navy SEAL because I still have that
in me right now you mean like I want to
[__] see how my limits are but
a Navy SEAL would have been cool you
mean not that I stand for the political
doc you know the government's cause or
nothing but I do stand for you I mean
honor and stuff like that I would like
to see how far I could have tested
myself
and at least it would have been cool to
have the basic training and stuff you
know I had to use it learning on the
streets but uh that's what I would have
done differently I would have become
more of a man that was more goal
oriented instead of just off the hook I
got the Feeling you'd make a hell of a
marine [__] yeah I would have made a
hell of a marine hell yeah yeah I don't
know I mean it's hard for me to take
orders so I'd have to get up there oh
that well yeah other than that yeah I
got hard I got a heart of a line dude
ain't nobody stopping me dude so all the
haters out here don't think they're
gonna come get it come get it home Boys
you ain't stopping me I mean ain't been
stopped since ain't been stopped now
and just so you know the dog's doing
good my dog's doing good because last
time I see some of the some of the
people on there ever ask about my dog my
dog's fine if you always get very
concerned about hurt dogs heck yeah and
he's fine dude I was gonna bring him on
here you know I mean as a matter of fact
but I thought he'd be crazy coming down
here all the way down here your dog got
shot right he got shot in the head but
he's fine he's fine I mean I killed the
person that did it myself defense but
yeah and then uh what else did I wanted
to clarify to you oh yeah well when I
said about victimizing people
I mean what did I say again I said uh
exerting my Authority or exhort exerting
something look I don't mean victimizing
anybody that's an innocent people the
way I constitute somebody that's got
something coming is the person that's in
the game right so if you're out there
and you're playing drugs and you're
doing drugs and your able-bodied dude
you ain't some dude it's in a wheelchair
or some some innocent person that can't
defend himself that's not the kind of
[__] I mean I'm not a bully I mean I go
but if you're in the game you're out
here puffing and toughing I come across
you and you don't finger defend your
[__] I'm gonna take a [__] I'm gonna
take a [__] and put you on the put you
in the spot why wouldn't I that's the
all we're all in the same game dog you
man but people that's what I meant by
innocence I don't I don't just do it to
innocent people I don't walk them and
Rob an old lady just because I can or
something I mean so I want that
clarified because people are like oh man
you're talking the same things you see
this and then you do this and as far as
somebody says something about a child
molester getting slashed yeah so
paperwork rules in prison I mean so some
people might have been innocent and
weren't child molesters and but we ain't
got time to do all that I know my whole
life I never had to worry about I've
never had a false asking accusation for
that kind of [__] I mean so if you have
it you must have been doing something
that was a long line to something that
got you [__] needed to get you [__]
up correct I'm not saying it's Justified
or nothing but it's just to me it's
Justified you mean I'm just gonna just
go ahead you mean how much time have you
spent in prison
I spent 14 years in prison straight
um before that out when I was in
juvenile hall if I got bus when I was 11
and I was like Junior Hall placement and
then got out for about maybe a year and
a half and the rest time was all pretty
much incarcerated and 18 a month after I
turned 18 I caught a carjacking
four years and then I caught another
consecutive term for slicing the child
molester on the print on the prison yard
and then I caught another term and so I
was all consecutive in there so they
stacked it for about 14 years ago prison
is not for you
for you yeah they'll leave right on here
but yeah it sucks in there dude it's
just very meat Bleak existence dude
but that's why some of the Polish words
I got and stuff like that that came from
a lot of time to to reflect though it
gives you time to reflect that's what it
does like I said out here you don't get
that time out here but in there I did I
mean but it was forced upon me in a way
that I I can't see some like internal
like all I have this capability to do it
but I was forced to do it so therefore I
was able to indulge in so I was able to
at least know myself a little bit better
than most people knowing their Sim cells
out here you know
life life is just as tough in prison as
it is on the streets for some people
[__] hell yeah dude I mean the only
thing that they provide you are the
basic needs the rest of it's all
navigation through people that are just
looking to stab you in the back the
thing I found out that was the most
challenging for me is in prison I
literally there was a time where I went
no business no nothing so I wasn't even
hugged from 18 to like 30. I didn't feel
no affection for nobody not like that
you mean like a chance he's from the
homeboys and [__] but I was in a place
where everybody could I had to hide
everything about themselves like any
vulnerability there was a was you know I
mean was it a straight up uh a red flag
you mean so anything you really felt
about something you held withheld you
mean like I remember meeting people are
like I already lose some black music I
don't even listen to uh oh that you got
to chew on they wouldn't even act like
they watched the TV they had a Jew in it
because they'd be like I'm super white
power of the fullest my mother are you
born in the 90s don't you tell me you
didn't hear Tupac growing up in high
school all of us did oh bro who's that
what they did they had to pretend to be
like that I was always myself
unfortunately because I can't be nothing
other than that I mean and people want
to hate on that but I'd rather be that
than some fake [__] but a lot of
people were in there like that you mean
they would be sitting there so [__]
outside the lube like come on bro you're
just [__] Adolf Hitler incarnate and
[__] never even heard of Jerry Seinfeld
I thought I like Jerry Seinfeld but like
[__] you won't even watch a TV show
that has a black dude or anything in it
like the whole shit's [__] stupid
yeah prison gets very uh very racial
very segregated yeah it is and it's but
it but you gotta remember you put a
bunch of people in this place where
there's not really nothing going on I
mean what else they got to trip on you
know I mean what they need to do this is
what I was talking about the other day
you got all these prison games right but
if they would have done it they would
have wasted their influence they should
done this they should have told
everybody going to the county jails
right everybody this is mandatory you
get green lighted [__] who you
guys go against this nobody take a deal
no more plea bargain lock up the courses
and straight up everybody in this County
Jail is going to go demand trial speedy
trial right now it would have locked the
[__] system up right especially in
Riverside County because they're running
out of courthouses it would have locked
the system up right boom then we would
have had leverage to negotiate that
would show the that would have showed
some intelligence instead of sitting
here causing riots over over [__]
Politics on prison bars and [__]
white cribs and [__] all that [__] we
should have came together as a unit
right and told the system straight up
[__] we're locking this [__] up then
they wouldn't have no courtrooms and
they would have been locked then you
could have told them like this we want
[__] uh District Attorneys to be held
accountable they want the immunity off
the table because district attorney
[__] prosecute you right and he could
be [__] running a [__] straight up
he knows you're innocent he doesn't give
a [__] just run you to dirt [__] do
whatever he wants why what what what's
him he's impunity dude he has nothing
that's going to come back and [__] him
over but you put that on at least on the
table like hey dude you [__] wreck
somebody's [__] live dog you're
asking yeah prison term two [__]
that might change the whole system down
all of a sudden you got a DA that wants
to do his job the right way I mean then
all these innocent people that they
refuse to let out or whatever the [__]
start to become less
then people start looking at crime a
little bit differently but I guess they
think they oh well we can do whatever we
[__] we want plus I had a homegirl that
worked in well I had a homeboy that knew
a chick that worked there she was this
like the senior person that worked in
the District Attorney's Office in
Riverside right
she was about to spawn out dude and she
came and told us straight up that
everybody all them all them officials in
there if you really pay attention to
them they're all on dope they're all
like Melrose Place [__] up in there and
I started going to court and watching
this [__] I'd be like
and you do they're walking they're not
[__] all twacked out and [__] like me
like no this is so cute
if you knew that what they were doing
behind closed doors like I told you
everybody has public face private face
they're just better they're in a better
position to get away with the [__] they
get away with you know what I mean just
like politicians nobody [__] arrest
politicians but
it's all about how you know how you
handle it you mean who you know you mean
but all the rest of us citizens we got
to go to [__] jail and get punished
and lose everything we got I mean I'm
not I'm seeing your dog out people that
got money but I'm just like
it's kind of [__] up you know
I mean you get on welfare track homeboy
and prison part of the life dude
you're not gonna have it without the
other side and now they've done it to so
much that the prison complex it's so big
that everybody's getting [__] over
dude like even rich kids are going to
jail and now it's like because there's
too many laws there's too much [__]
you know and if anything you should go
back to where we all had straps you know
me like we were supposed to have and if
[__] wrong G call them out to
the streets and just [__] Desperado
that [__] I mean
[__] everyone's carrying a gun well yeah
but you know they say the crime rate is
down people that have guns in
communities where they have more gun
carries I mean but uh
I'm not saying they wouldn't you know
some people don't some people are
convinced that guns should be removed
from the planet I don't think so I mean
so what are you going to do defend
yourself you know
they don't even put that into context
they just think they're [__] if we
had no guns you know any [__] crazy
as [__] I want to have guns and I don't
think the government should be able to
dictate any of us having drugs I mean
not like that I don't think you should
be get busted for some other crime that
has nothing to do with any of that [__]
and then you lose your right to bear
arms that's a constitutional right that
shouldn't be superseded by [__] law
laws do not supersede the constitutional
rights of a [__] human
but you know at the same time the
Constitution wasn't written for none of
us anyways you know I mean it was
written by these [__] for these
[__] they interpreted however
they want to interpret it dog so we're
over here [__] jaw jacking when none
of it really matters you know I don't
really matter not these days
what do you think what do you think
about politics I I stay away from
certain topics religion politics smart
man smart man women's weight yeah yeah a
smart man dude smart man I would say
away from him too man
ain't no ain't nothing for us it's even
bicker about I mean but
what do you see in your future would you
like to be in five years ah five years
now let's see
if everything works out gotta
a Wills or whatever you know permits I'd
like to be seeing myself with some kind
of foundation that I want now because
now I'm starting to concentrate on
actually building something you mean I
want to maybe explore the podcast
situation where I can maybe Enlighten
some people and help people I mean I
want to be able to um
I know that what I went through is
enough that in the right hands or the
right ears here that it can influence
some people you know I mean and I wanted
to work on my kids but I also wanted to
work on anybody else that's struggling
I want to try to start providing some
kind of more legal I know I can't get
into legal sector to make sure that you
do that they want to take that away from
you as far as selling it but I'll I'll
be a I'll be a consultant to anybody
that wants help than anything when it
goes with law because I've been studying
that [__] since I was a kid obviously so
I'll help anybody because every lawyer
out here is crooked dude if you get
injured in a car accident don't go look
too lower come to me I mean I started my
YouTube channel I want to promote that a
little bit my go for me for my personal
thing I mean so that I can build
something but I would like to build a
podcast or meet some other people out
there that want me on their show or
whatever I'll come on I mean but I know
a lot of a lot of stuff about that stuff
and I probably try to help people out
with that or maybe start something where
I could help people that are like kids
that are starting to go off in a bad
Direction maybe giving them a little bit
more
more of an Insight that's more touching
you know the scare straight [__] I never
thought that was a good approach for
kids is that anything but most boys when
they're young they got the full piss and
vinegar I mean so when they're already
on a bad path like I wouldn't do that do
that [__] too when I was already in a
bad path and then I got this confidence
and I'm like well I want beef tough
[__] so you're just gonna you're
just challenging me to [__] prove
that I am it's more of a challenge than
it is pouring the gas on a fire so I
never thought that was a good approach
but I think if they really got to the
bottom of what is the eventual [__]
this is as bad as it [__] gets being
a segregated cell where no matter how
powerful like the gang members they get
powerful super like [__] validated
[__] top at the top of the [__]
list they're in the Box dude there it
doesn't matter how many people talk
about your name when you're in a [__]
box at the end of the day it's you that
box in the malls and no matter what
[__] gang name you got what the [__]
does that matter really what does it
matter it's bizarre but you won't
realize that until you're all the way
here and you're stuck then he's like oh
this is what the [__] you mean but it's
over by that time you mean so I would
like to be able to help people see the
inner workings to the point where they
really get a feel of it I mean I don't
know how you do that maybe I'll figure
out something but social media is a
powerful tool yeah and you have some
strong opinions that are gonna be a
magnet on social media I hope so I hope
so I'll stand by any one of them because
everything I've ever spoken on in my
life I live by I live by or I've went
through and I don't think I don't think
you'll it'll wear in the test of time I
don't think it'll change my viewpoints
on it because I don't see any any faults
in the viewpoints that I have and if I
do then challenge them you mean but I'm
telling you right now as a white kid
from Southern California
games are everywhere because that's just
part of our [__] makeup As Americans
we all had games whether white gangs
whatever the [__] and secondly if you're
poor and you ain't got nothing you're
going to get your hustle on that's
that's American Way really you know what
I mean the only difference is the elite
are gonna make sure that people like
that they got a different soul ain't
gonna be up there dog so you're gonna
have to find another way to penetrate
that and if it's selling your soul or
whatever they say about all that [__] I
don't know but I know that if you're
gonna do it you got to build it you
gotta see stay steadfast on it I mean
and make sure that you don't do [__]
that's [__] up to people because if
you do [__] that [__] the people Karma's
gonna come back on you Karma's Karma's
real isn't it a form of karma is real
yeah for a fact I believe I believe I
believe in karma I think if you go
through life doing things that you
shouldn't be doing to people it'll
figure out a way to snap you in the ass
I guarantee you will and that's and
that's not even a joke it'll just be
your own self yeah your your
subconscious will will make it happen
yeah and you know like some people like
what about these [__] foul [__] like
Hitler or whatever if you want to
promote Hitler as a [__] foul person
whatever the [__] but and he didn't he
had his demise maybe he didn't who knows
but I'm saying like Karma comes back in
the form of different ways dude like
maybe when you die you're [__] your
next Generations all come back to
cockroaches I don't [__] know but I
definitely don't want to find out dude I
definitely don't want to do [__] the
person that has a conscience knows
better they know that that's harming
themselves and they [__] wrong people
if they're real good people they know
that it hurts from the moment they do
this [__] and they feel bad about it
even if they don't know how to admit it
to you most people have done bad [__] I
know when I've done bad [__] I feel bad
about it still to this day but I don't
want to sit here and carry guilt because
that's a waste of time too but I know
that [__] a good person will always
know when he does something wrong try to
do something to rectify it you know what
I mean yeah
Billy Baker thank you so much thank you
you're amazing thank you both